The heroes and villains of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe got snap-happy in Avengers: Endgame,
and one click of the fingers created a potential
problem for a much-loved character: Zoe Saldana's
Gamora.
Avengers: Endgame directors Joe and Anthony
Russo have addressed the green-skinned heroine's
fate, but their answer isn't as crystal-clear
as most fans might hope.
After Avengers: Endgame leaps forward five
years to the year 2023 following the fallout
of Avengers: Infinity War, the surviving heroes
concoct a plan to travel back in time, collect
the Infinity Stones ahead of when Thanos took
them, then jump to the present to equip their
own Infinity Gauntlet and resurrect their
fallen compatriots.
"Time travel!"
The time heist is successful, despite a number
of hiccups along the way, and the heroes who
were dusted in Infinity War came back to life
to fight a final battle against Thanos.
But those characters weren't the only ones
who returned to the MCU in Endgame: Gamora
did, too - but as the 2014 version of herself
prior to Guardians of the Galaxy and prior
to her death in Infinity War.
She showed up in 2023 after Professor Hulk
used his Infinity Gauntlet to bring back the
dusted heroes, and before Tony Stark snapped
his fingers to decimate Thanos and his army.
This raised a pressing question: If 2018 Gamora
was killed when Thanos sacrificed her to obtain
the Soul Stone in Infinity War, what happened
to 2014 Gamora after Tony's snap?
Chatting with Business Insider's Travis Clark,
the Russos said that there's an equal chance
that 2014 Gamora was spared in Tony's snap
as there is the possibility she died alongside
Thanos and his supporters.
Additionally, Marvel fans will likely have
to wait until Guardians of the Galaxy Vol.
3 hits theaters sometime in the future to
learn what really happened to Gamora after
Tony's snap.
Shutting down any speculation about whether
Gamora's fellow Guardians know the answer,
Anthony Russo added that Star-Lord is just
as in the dark as fans are.
Joe Russo then noted that he's confident "future
films will answer that question."
When Clark commented that it's up to Guardians
Vol. 3 director James Gunn to fully unravel
the mystery, Anthony agreed, saying, quote,
"Exactly, we've done our job."
It's not all that implausible to think that
2014 Gamora may have survived the climactic
battle between Thanos and the Avengers, despite
her seemingly being considered a part of Thanos'
intergalactic army and not appearing in physical
form after Tony's snap.
She does, however, show up on a screen map
in the Guardians' ship the Benatar at the
end of the film.
It seems evident that Star-Lord and the rest
of the team will embark on a mission to locate
Gamora in Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3.
Considering how pivotal to the franchise Gamora
has been, it's only right that she would emerge
once more for the trilogy-ender.
If and when Gamora returns in the third Guardians
film, it's basically guaranteed that the heroine
will be the 2014 Gamora who flashed forward
in time in Endgame.
The Gamora who played a part in the first
two Guardians movies and Avengers: Infinity
War is dead and cannot be revived.
As Endgame co-writer Christopher Markus once
explained,
"When Gamora went off that cliff [in Infinity
War] the Gamora from that time period died."
Joe Russo confirmed elsewhere when speaking
about Black Widow's death that non-snap deaths
are permanent.
He said:
"[The] process is irreversible.
Even if you have returned [the Soul Stone]
to its original location, you wouldn't be
able to get the person back.
In fact, it's not really returning the stone,
more like put it back properly.
The tribute soul for the Soul Stone will forever
be sealed in that place, therefore Black Widow
is gone forever."
If Black Widow and Gamora experienced the
same demise, that means 2018 Gamora is gone
forever as well.
Past Gamora may not be, though.
And even if she was dusted when Tony snapped
his fingers, there's a chance she could return
to life in Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Avengers:
Endgame are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.